bueno tenemos la información que ha
venido dando especialmente el grupo
talibán hablan de 13 muertos y de
múltiples heridos todavía no sabemos
cuál lo que sí sabemos en las imágenes
que van llegando de muchísimas personas
siendo transportadas en cualquier medio
que haya posible hay muchísimas
ambulancias tratando de despejar las
personas de este sector es que
a
dónde fueron estas dos explosiones
suicidas el ser luperón citados tanto
por ejemplo los ciudadanos británicos o
aquellos que tenían el salvoconducto
para viajar con los británicos pero
también con con los españoles y muchos
otros países para llegar allí y poder
acceder al aeropuerto recordemos que han
sido durante días muy difícil poder
llegar hasta allí porque tenían que
pasar esos controles de los talibanes y
muchísima gente después de hacerlo se
apiñaba en este lugar tratando de tener
acceso al aeropuerto lo que era cada vez
más difícil con las horas con la medida
que se acerca esta fecha límite era más
complicado así lo que posiblemente dicen
que el número de muertos y heridos
mayores estamos a la espera de conocer
más y hablan incluso de que hay mujeres
y niños entre ellos la información de
inteligencia hablaba de que el
autodenominado estado islámico podría
cometer un atentado que tan posible es
esto
bueno eso es lo que han venido barajando
las fuerzas de inteligencia tanto
norteamericanas como británicas en los
últimos días y hoy ya la alarma estaba
aprendida recordemos que este es el
estado islámico de jorasán que es la
rama de esta organización terrorista en
afganistán cya habla de que en los
últimos meses más gente y más seguidores
de este grupo han entrado al país desde
diferentes diferentes fronteras no es
que sea una organización extremadamente
grande pero sí ha sido capaz de tener
ataques muy
mortíferos en el pasado un par de
ataques en kabul en los últimos años que
han dejado muchísimos muertos así que
tienen capacidad para hacer daño y esto
es una gran reto para los talibanes la
primera vez en 20 años que ellos tienen
el control realmente de la seguridad de
la ciudad y ahora tienen que responder
ellos contra esos ataques terroristas
que ellos antes hacían bueno y el 31 de
agosto era la fecha límite para que
terminarán las evacuaciones de las
tropas extranjeras usted cree que esta
explosión aceleraría su salida
bueno hay países que ya dijeron que
entre hoy y mañana van a acabar sus
operaciones canadá acaba de cerrar todas
sus operaciones españa francia alemania
también ha hablado de que las próximas
horas van a cerrar las operaciones así
que cada vez se cierran más de ese
margen para aquellos que quieren salir
del país a eeuu tiene que empezar a
evacuar a sus tropas también que tiene
en el aeropuerto una ambición
extremadamente complicada así que
posiblemente las próximas horas son
durante el fin de semana empezarán a
mermar el número de personas que sacan
para empezar a sacar a los efectivos